[Music]
have you guys heard
of the wildly popular travis scott
meal yeah being offered at mcdonald's
they didn't even [ __ ]
contact me i thought i was their
ambassador and [ __ ] i saw review bro
reviewed this do you know who
reviewbower is
no tim tim delegate the one that tastes
food in his car
yes well and in his home with his little
[ __ ] chalice and [ __ ] okay
he's a guy he wears like a [ __ ] suit
yeah and he's like the redhead kid
yeah he's super aryan he's the most
aryan person ever lived red hair is not
aries no he's not redheaded he's like oh
i don't know i don't know if it's red
huh i picture him as a redhead
carrot tops are not they're like the
runts of the the
the lineage right i think so i don't
know i didn't study this
it should be yeah but no but he reviews
food so he was talking about this travis
scott thing
but i didn't understand what i didn't
understand i only saw this because tim
posted about it
oh i haven't seen this at all what is it
i saw it because of casey's brother
he follows travis scott and all that and
so he it's it's a meal
that travis scott like this is what he
would
order in his childhood home of houston
but wasn't it like a full mcdonald's
campaign though like they made it
available yes yes i'm going to play the
ad
that is promoting this meal so you guys
can believe they didn't reach out to me
man
well take it up with the mcdonald's gum
that's a nice picture oh there's
barbecue sauce travis likes to eat
barbecue sauce with fries here we go
barbecue sauce
what's up world yeah i'm travis scott
this is playmation follow me
here's my quarter pounder with lettuce
pickles onions ketchup mustard and bacon
here's my fries sometimes i do this
then i dip them in the barbecue sauce oh
yeah and my sprite
yeah he's like me orders is back in
houston you could try too
gotta go that does look pretty good
he got a beat like dr jackson what was
what is that base a quarter pounder and
he added lettuce and
bacon and bacon so he asked for quarter
pounder he goes give me lettuce and
bacon yes that's so smart
[ __ ] a sprite a quarter pounder with
bacon
and lettuce and ketchup and mustard and
then a barbecue sauce for the french
fries
yes so exactly so it's it's fresh beef
bacon onions let's not say fresh beef
that's not to live that's mcdonald's
dude this is just the beginning guys
like i think this is going to be huge
like more collapse
so this isn't the first time they've
done a collab
before but it is they've collabed before
and i remember that
they have they collabed 30 years ago
with michael jordan oh i was just going
to see michael jordan
michael jordan was collabing with nike
and all kinds of different
companies back then i wonder if he did
one and he did
that's so cool what what was it uh i
don't have it on hand let me see
chicken nuggets big mac he also collabed
with [ __ ] domino's pizza before the
flu game
you know this overshadowed their other
big release which was the spicy nuggets
spicy nuggets they just really spicy
nuggets did it overshadow the spicy
nuggets really it overshadowed he did
because i didn't know about it he's
disappointed like a mcdonald's historian
here
that he didn't get asked because he's an
ambassador
did they tell you that's maybe the
funniest thing i've ever heard in my
life
that you're pissed that they it
overshadowed the spicy nuggets launched
did they invite you to the spicy nuggets
at least no other my friends got that
too
wow the last time i was a part of it was
their big bacon campaign and that was
last
year in the spring you're one of their
low tier influencers
think of all the people who never got to
be in the campaigns at all that's me
me i was their bigger one well casey did
yeah but that's not me
i was in a commercial you guys are like
one but that's not me
i'm my own person i have my own identity
what would the casey chan mail be
meal we all like yin and yang i don't
know we really are i don't know
you don't know what your husband would
order at mcdonald's do you even know him
at all i don't know him at all you think
i know him i don't know my husband is he
a fish-fillet kind of guy
no he's a quarter-pounder guy he's more
like travis scott
yeah i don't eat none of those you don't
like fish fillet what's the jojo meal at
mcdonald's chicken nuggets chicken
hamburgers with french fries inside
hamburgers and french fries inside
that is cute that you know his meal that
was really cute
that's a marriage yeah you're married
extra ketchup
extra ketchup that's a marriage yup
what's your meal then
uh wait let joe let's go let's go oh
he's not gonna get it he's not gonna get
it going
wait can i actually do this it's
filet-o-fish
yeah because i just said that no but you
always get filet-o-fish
sometimes he gets nuggets yes and then
um
he gets large fries with the extra large
coke with extra ice cream
that was really cute guys you put okay
i've never seen joe be more romantic
with anyone
that's true that's true how is that
romantic
it was really romantic if you remember
you don't know what it does to women to
remember that kind of thing
really years i've known you joe this is
the most romantic oh my god if you hear
it long enough
it's just going to incept your brain
that's what a marriage is
yeah i guess so so just be annoying just
don't just listen
just listen to the annoying repetitive
[ __ ] that's it
you're projecting the annoying
repetitiveness [ __ ] just be like oh
that's what they need
that's what my bart needs that's my
party i'm cute
that's from my boyfriend that's what my
bar needs i'm just listening to him it's
not annoying repetitive [ __ ]
that's what my bar needs that's so funny
okay now bird dude
yeah do me two cheeseburgers french
fries
sprite i'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you got the number two yeah i could beat
you on basic
my or my go-to mcdonald's order is the
number one big mac with no onions that's
it with a coke
then onions is not basic though yeah if
you had onions that would be so basic so
basically
and you got the number one which is
that's your flagship thing yeah that's
tiny which is more basic and now let me
order for my wife okay
okay uh do you guys have burgers right
okay is it vegan
take the patty out please take the patty
out just the cheese that's fine and you
keep making a grilled cheese sandwich
nikki gets us
right she wouldn't get a filet-o-fish
she's a pescatarian well there's the
cheese in there never seen order it i
yeah i've never ordered a fish from
mcdonald's i have done their breakfast
though
that i do the egg mcmuffin with no
cheese but they also do their fries in
the beef fat
so i don't know so i don't know if she
could have the fries good for you for
knowing that
oh i didn't know that yeah only a few
you just got to listen you know it's not
annoying [ __ ] is it
no no it's pretty [ __ ] annoying plus
they changed their fries anyway like
they used to be way
better back when back in the 90s really
yeah oh yeah
they were saucy yeah exactly
morgan spurlock super size me guy oh
he's like oh this stuff's so bad for you
and then mcdonald's like oh don't worry
we're gonna make our fries look super
more healthy now
we can't make it like in and out fries
and in-n-out fries are the worst fries
the worst fries in all of the before
that everything was fried and lard right
and then people
started talking about trans fat and
until everyone started
doing vegetable oil peanut oil whatever
and then that's what changed the game i
heard that with this thing like they're
having shortages and [ __ ] because it's
so popular exactly that's exactly what
the story is here is the fact that they
are having shortages across the nation
because of this meal
so that's a successful collab then yeah
so it's it's a quarter pounder with
cheese sizzling bacon
crisp lettuce medium fries with barbecue
sauce to dip
and a sprite and then i googled michael
jordan's meal from back in 1992
and it was a cheeseburger on a sesame
seed bun
it had pickles raw onion slices bacon
and barbecue sauce
so they ran out of quarter pounders
they they wrap they're running out of
simple ingredients like lettuce
bacon burgers burger patties yeah
barbecue sauce
how do you how does mcdonald's run out
of things that's what i don't understand
they underestimated how popular
this [ __ ] is yeah and also they since
nothing is fresh
they gotta call in the lettuce exactly
they're saying that they're
they can't go to ralph's they're talking
to the suppliers to like so right now
the way that they're handling the
shortage is
is franchisees that already have a stock
they will not be getting restocked for
some time so they can go through that
stock and then the ones that are in dire
need of stock they will immediately get
get uh replenished the people who live
in more travis scott areas apparently
because apparently not all areas are
participating yeah i heard that they
inject their lettuce with sugar water
what
yeah to make it more addicting like when
they came out with salads that was like
the whole scandal was that like it
wasn't actually healthier because they
injected their lettuce with sugar water
believe it
it made it more is it reflected in
the nutrition facts like the salad has
like hella carbs i don't know
i never looked jack did you think they
water it with sugar water like
at the mcdonald's lettuce farm it's like
soaking it like idiocracy
they just feed them energy drinks yeah
or do you think
when they chop it out they wash it in
like sugar water
oh like you know how like when they
clean it they they just chop it up and
then they throw it in a bucket
like that's how restaurants actually
rinse vegetables do they put like drops
of
or probably like a spray maybe sugar
water
sugar yeah i wonder if it's tastier yeah
that might be a good idea i don't know
do it to your lettuce
i know you guys want to order it if it's
if it's available the point of the
article apparently
yes yes the point which we're not
sponsor by the way but it's
it's called sold out it's called the
cactus jack because that is
travis scott's nickname and record label
name
really and so this meal is called the
cactus jack and he doesn't seem very
cactusy to me but i've actually been
curious and never wanted to try it
and then casey today because isaac's
been asking to try it
and just today he was texting me that
they
he tried to get it and they didn't have
it sold out
yeah so funny all it takes is just
somebody you're
like oh yeah i like this guy and this is
what he gets when he goes there
because it's really not that complicated
a quarter pounder with cheese with bacon
on it
and i've pretty easy fries and barbecue
sauce we all have
but you're still i still want to try
this it makes it more tastier when it's
branded a certain what does a quarter
pounder come with
because the quarter pound cheese with
the onions it doesn't come with the
lettuce i think it's
yeah it's the lettuce in the in the
bacon right that's ketchup and mustard i
think
yeah it's just the meat with the two
cheese things and then mcdonald's always
dices the [ __ ] out of their onions
somehow yeah yeah cause it's not yeah
it's not even that crazy it's not like
the making bang
exactly like that what's that it's like
cheeseburger and a mixed spice and a
mcchicken
can i get the big gang bang awesome
extra meat extra extra meat it's the
awesome caramel
so try that one out i bet you one day
that's gonna happen one [ __ ] day 200
years from now idiocracy style
you have a porn star that'd be great
well they should keep this up though is
the collab with people
and like have people just create their
meals because
obviously it's a success so i i'm
also curious like what else are they
gonna come up with who else are they
gonna
collab with i can't believe no one knows
about the spicy nuggets
right it's crazy i know about the spices
i gotta google it i haven't tried it yet
maybe they're not that spicy
[Music]
[Music]
so